so Call of Duty warzone might just be
the best battle royale ever and since
its release there's actually a lot of
numbers to support that you know what
guys this might be the fortnight killer
[Music]
now you may have noticed that I'm not in
that stool in the office and that's
because like many others we're taking
all precautions necessary to prevent the
spread of the kovat 19 virus and that
means for the next little while you're
gonna get some sweet donat Me's from our
various homes make sure you keep washing
your hands alright so let's get into war
zone and I know what you're thinking
another battle royale baked into an FPS
title what makes it better than all the
other attempts at this well I'm here to
tell you that all the signs are pointing
to this game being different so
different in fact that war zone is
shattering records from its predecessors
three days after the game's release it
reached fifteen million players
worldwide
that's five million more than apex in
the same timeframe and they took
fortnight six months to reach twenty
million players these numbers alone make
warzone the fastest growing non mobile
game of all time now Call of Duty tried
this before as I'm sure a lot of you
remember with black out in black ops 4
and it had a reasonable start you know a
lot of people were playing it on Twitch
but it certainly didn't catch on the way
war zone has remember guys you actually
had to buy black ops 4 to play black it
this is the first free-to-play it called
duty battle royale now before I get into
the details of what's made this game
work let's go over what actually warzone
offers as you might imagine it works
similar to other battle Royales you have
a hundred and fifty player maximum
lobbies there's a circle closing in
except instead of the storm like
fortnight it's gas this time everybody
starts with just a pistol and you work
in three player teams honestly on its
surface it's actually very similar to
apex but it feels like the size and
scope of this game it's just way bigger
than we've seen with other battle rails
which is exactly what doc said it's
actually a very interesting space to
fight in because if you'll notice that
this the world scale the scale actually
feels pretty good like it feels like I'm
running around in a bigger space and you
could tell when you're in a certain area
that's one thing that stuck out to me in
the play test is that you like you know
that you're at the airport I mean it's
it's really it's not like buildings
right into an airport right into the
stadium into a mountain behind it it's
everything spaced out nicely
look there's no understanding the
popularity of battery house all the way
back to h1z1
then pub G and then fortnight and now
warzone these games are like a streamers
dream the game is actually fairly casual
it doesn't feel like competitive
matchmaking in csgo but it's those exact
same things that made these games fun
that have had hardcore FPS fans turn the
nose up at them even back at the office
the csgo heads in a Rainbow six siege
heads they scoff at games like fortnight
because they're just simply not
competitive enough and that's where
warzone comes in what sets this game
apart is its ability to balance that
casual and competitive side of things on
a Razors Edge it has all the best
aspects of previous BRS but with some
much-needed skill testing additions the
first is that it's simply a refined Call
of Duty game this game is just Cod and
there is already a fully built out
competitive eSports scene around the
second and maybe most importantly is the
buyback system when you die in war zone
you get sent to the Gulag if you get the
opportunity to 1v1 someone to get back
in the game this means that if you're
the best team in the lobby and you have
an unfortunate early game or you get
unlucky with loot you have a chance to
come back and then win the game later
lastly the addition of a simple
financial system that allows you to make
sure when you go to the light game you
have the loadout you need the armor you
need and all the utility you need to
succeed if any of you have played for at
night you know that feeling of heading
into the late game with no shield and
just knowing that you're like imagine
you you collect enough currency and then
with that currency you could buy shields
or you could buy a launch pad right for
me that just sounds really cool and I
think I think epic might eventually do
some effect basically what all this
means is that when you play warzone you
never feel like you lost in the late
game because somebody got luckier than
you and when it comes to battle Royales
I think that is a huge win because
that's been a lot of people's biggest
complaints with the genre for years and
you don't have to just take my word for
it as with every new BR Twitch's biggest
names are all over Wars
I think I just saw scope I'm gonna get
position position now as you might
imagine with that 15 million player
number war zone has been dwarfing the
competition since its release the game
has had higher viewership than both apex
and fortnight over the last week on
Twitch with all this in mind it might
not just be the actual game that has led
to this popularity much like myself many
people around the world have been
isolated to their homes due to the
spread of covet 19 and in places like
Italy where the virus has already caused
mass quarantine we've seen a 70 percent
spike in Internet traffic and that's
according to Bloomberg and in their
report they actually attribute that
spike to an increase in playing of video
games by young people staying home from
school now for all the good things I've
said about warzone there's always gonna
be a honeymoon period with new games
hell some of the biggest streamers are
still being paid to play shroud while
being impressed with the game in general
has already noted a few things that he'd
like to change I mean it is really
really fast it really is but it's you
can't that's the thing you can't balance
its near impossible to bet balance ttk
in Call of Duty because like they're
their main focus is to try to combine
all aspects of the game multiplayer
Battle Royale
like all these all these modes are like
connected right and summit who's been
streaming to like 40,000 people at a
time since warzone released also said
that the time to kill was too fast and
he says that the vehicles in the game
are just broke oh my gosh that truck in
the blue car or o-p-s
yeah I wrote you overall downwind oh
yeah it's insane bro wait you can't
shoot through the front window on the
[ __ ] truck I had no idea that that's
crazy
but those gripes in mind Infinity Ward
has actually set up a tracker so that
they can keep track of known bugs and
let everyone know where are these fixes
and when these fixes are coming which is
an insane commitment from a developer
now obviously there's still a lot of
time before we know whether or not war
zone is gonna be the fortnight killer or
whether they can coexist or if it's just
gonna die off like black out did but
there's one thing I can tell you for
sure
when I log off at the end of the day
today I am definitely getting some games
in Colin Colin you should actually try
this game you know like when you start a
battle royale you get that feeling where
like you don't belong where you just
like land and die every game like it's
not really like that like because it's
called duty there's like familiarity and
like you know there's lots of mechanics
that allow you to keep playing I think
it makes it kind of awesome